[Music]
[Music]
yeah so good morning everyone I hope you
enjoyed the conference so far yes I did
a my talks already but I'm still nervous
so it doesn't disappear no all right
today I will talk about taming reactive
nodejs basically so we'll dive into the
stream oriented architectures and I will
show you how nest framework can greatly
help you with implementation of such
streams during systems before we move to
the main topic I would like to quickly
introduce myself real quick because we
don't have too much time
my name is Camille I'm a co-founder of
chillin i/o the next level software
counseling company and I basically I'm a
software engineer primarily focusing the
web related things you can find me on
Twitter using this highlighted red
Twitter handle and obviously on the
github beyond regular day to day work
I'm giving the value back to the
community as an open source contributor
I'm the creator of Nass GS which is
basically the fastest rising and the
most popular framework for node.js in
2018 in the last year we have noted 300%
growth in the popularity in number of
github stars living behind any other
existing famous library like express
kaha features all of them
which is pretty amazing and regarding
nest maybe let's start with the question
who has settled nest already please
write on Han woo all right 50% maybe 20%
25% so just you ensure that everyone is
on the same page it's a framework for
server-side applications writing
server-side applications not about note
GS it's written entirely in time squid
but remains the compatibility with pure
vanilla JavaScript so if you prefer a
yes/no words you can use it also it's
heavily inspired by angular but it
doesn't mean that you necessarily have
to use angular you can use view you can
use react it's up to you all right let's
firstly ask ourselves a question what is
the stream oriented architecture so
Civic architecture is basically just a
fancy name over secured s button so
common query responsibility segregation
in which you have some kind of
in Commons domain queries domain events
and all of them occur over time so all
these elements form streams what is a
stream so this is a simple stream on the
slide as a kind of timeline like one
line and you can see a number of events
on the time I said every circle is a
kind of event and they are couldn't
occur randomly sometimes you cannot
predict one so it's a kind of data set
in which you have values a synchronously
instead of synchronous it's like an
array but you don't have every value in
place you get them all the time
you have to weigh like one minute break
even two minutes break even and so on
and so on
so normally you more or less expect that
code that you ride is going to execute
incrementally like complete
incrementally and this model on the
other hand we have to slightly switch
our mindset we have to think about like
start finis reactively once we have
uneven we have to process it once we
have a comment we have to react we have
to execute some business logic
associated with this set and even our
common what are they maybe let's start
with advantages what are the advantages
of such stream driven architecture so
surely at least are more readable code
we have handlers that have one
responsibility ever change in our system
has to be preceded by a some kind of
even occurrence actually common
occurrence so it's a predictability as
well everything has its own place
additionally your application is loosely
coupled which means that you can easily
avoid this domino effect once you change
something is not gonna broke the rest of
the application and your elements are
kind of self describable usually have
very descriptive names so you can look
at the name even the names of the events
to have a kind of high like high
overview of the architecture what was
going on right now in your system high
level ideas and so on and so on
Rhett's let's real quick jump to the
disadvantages right now so I would say
that there is a one huge disadvantage er
which boils down to a few other ones
smaller ones but generally it's called
complexity so lots of boilerplate code
has to be written down to achieve even
even simple operations
for instance a great example Redux lots
of people like everybody who is writing
from the applications nowadays is
familiar with read acts as a state
management solution right and redux it
kind of inspired by seeker s by even
driven architectures and we know that
Redux gives you an excellent advantages
like you have a death tolls you have a
predictability you have a want data flow
one way data flow but the problem is if
you want to increase the value for
example which normally should be like
write one line of code with plus plus
variable or variable plus plus you have
to create an action you have to create a
reducer we have to create a selector
lots of stuff so that's the problem
reiax is great but you have a lot of
overhead and this is what I'm gonna show
today but in case like in server-side
applications so talking about the fury
is always a good background for our
knowledge but I'm gonna show I'm gonna
show you an example how to transform a
services layered architecture so this
common approach nowadays to our typical
stream oriented one will face some
challenges will contrast both solutions
and so on so what we are gonna do let's
assume that we a kind of game in which
heroes have to slay dragons right you
have to slay as many dragons as possible
the hero will then get points of
experience making an item I get some
coins and stuff like that and we
obviously do not have enough time to
cover every business functionality so
we'll only like take care of this one
single endpoint are something that we
are creating REST API and this endpoint
takes such body of the reakless only
dragon ID so they are at architecture
maybe let's briefly look at the design
like diagram we have a controller so it
basically is our transfer layer which
takes requests and response answers to
the users we got a service layer which
holds every business functionalities and
we have a data access abstraction over
our database over our even log or
something like that and let's move to
the code right now so in nest you can
create endpoints declare in the
declarative way so basically you can use
a patch
get and stuff like that over on the
merits itself in order to extract input
variables you are using the curators as
well so here we are using param to get
the hero ID from the endpoint and we are
using dragon ID to extract the dragon ID
from the body of the request and then we
are consequently executing associated
net a corresponding merit in the in the
service layer service on the other hand
holds the business logic business
functionalities so assuming that we have
this hero service which has r1 merit
slay dragon this is the body of the
matter we don't have enough time to just
like explain everything in detail so
just to give you like high-level view we
have to fetch these entities which is a
synchronous operation from the database
once we have Hiro and the dragon our
business functionality is to increase
points of experience at set a status of
the dragon to force because dragon like
we just killed the dragon so it's not a
life anymore it's pretty simple two
lines of code and then we obviously have
to save these operations to the database
using our reference little recent update
our entities to reflect our changes and
let's say sequel databases and in best
case it it should be wrap in the
transaction because we want to update
hero and the dragon never one of them
only all right we have our baseline we
have our game created already the
problem is that it doesn't have many
functionalities in place so we started
to introduce more features one of these
artifacts so every time when hero kills
the dragon it has an opportunity to get
a knight and like a swart
or like a shell to protect yourself so
that business logic business
functionality is pretty simple here
every time when you kill the dragon
which level is higher than free you are
getting random item again like four
lines of code nothing else get random
item a synchronous operation can cut the
array of items and that's said cool we
have another feature now let's think
about currency we need a way to buy
drinks like buy
by food by the hero and so on and so on
we need some kind of currents so we have
introduced coins what's the business
functionality business requirement here
every time so there is a one way every
time when hero kills the dragon there is
30% probability to get random number of
coins quite simple
the second thing every time when the
hero gets an item there is again 30% of
probability to get an item right so we
have two different ways to get an item
and to get our coins and and actually
that's it that's our game finished so
that's what that was our layered
architecture once we endpoint now we are
gonna move from the layered architecture
to the stream oriented one
so taking us to back to our slate dragon
method from the controller from the
heroes controller we've been calling
services Mel service matters but right
now in Sweden an architecture insecure
ass
we don't have services layer anymore
instead we have comments we have queries
we have evens so what we have to do we
have to execute and even a comment what
is a comment so in the Redux you have an
action action is above comment and even
at once well in a typical security
architecture you have separately
comments and events comment is a kind of
request for a change so I'm requesting
that the dragon has been killed by the
by the hero has to be killed by the hero
it's pretty simple class which has two
properties here OID dragon a that's it
and the comment bus is provided out of
the box by the nest GS secure s package
so you don't have to worry about an
internal implementation what you the
only thing that you have to worry about
is that as a kind of stream all right we
have dispatched a comment now we have to
process it and how to process the
comment we have to create a common
handler in order to create a common
handler in a declarative way we again
are using decorator so we have a class
which implements an interface I come on
tumblr and we have a common Handler
decorator but
most crucial thing here is that we have
to put the type of the comment here so
as you can see you can you can have
automatically bind your comment with our
expected a common handler by the
framework alright and every common
handler has an execute merit this
execute merit takes the common as an
input parameter what we have to do
similarly as in the services layer we
have to extract the hero ID and the
dragon lady then we have to get this
entities from the database right it's
just copy-paste there nothing has
changed here then we have to perform our
business logic the increase points of
experience said dragon starts to utilize
the false that's it we are done however
what we have to do as well we have to
dispatch an event we have to notify the
rest of the application that something
has changed right we cannot just change
this value so we have to notify the rest
of vacation the rest of the application
that something is happen and we have to
use events for that so what we have done
right now we have created a merit which
is a slight dragon of the hero entity
and I will show this just matter later
on what is the most important here is a
hero comet so every time when you change
something you have to commit your
changes similarly as in the git
repository so this is the slay dragon
medal that I should that I talked about
we have this this typical business logic
here these experience Ragland is alive
but the most important part is this
apply so now we are dispatching and even
and we have a domain event which is hero
slight dragon even this class has only
properties here OID dragon ID dragon
level experience points it doesn't have
merits it doesn't have get a setter so
the implementation is useless the only
thing that we have to be aware of is
that it has these properties like a box
for values as a kind of domain wrapper
for for for this properties all right I
know that it might getting confused like
confusing so let's like look at the high
level architecture overview right now
again we have a comment
every comment is processed by the
appropriate common handler we don't have
services anymore every common handler
using is using domain models or is
dispatching events directly and now the
missing piece of our architecture every
event has to be handled by the even
handler what is that even handler almost
the same thing as in that common
handlers but the only difference is that
we have to implement a different
interface which is eieven handler and we
have to use a different decorator which
is events handler and again the most
important part we have to pass the type
here so framework will take care of the
whole have a lifting underneath you
don't have to worry about the
association between comments and comment
on letters between events and events
handler we are gonna do it automatically
out of the box
which is super awesome and every event
has to handle like ever even handler has
to handle even it gets an input this
input is this particular even and as you
can see there is a comment here
persistent logic so what he can do you
can log your events you can save those
events you can basically do whatever you
want to but since we want to reflect our
services architecture we would have to
copy-paste this piece of the code and
put it here so we are extracting hero ID
he wrote a dragon ID experience points
and we have to update the database but
there is a problem the problem is that
it's very tough very difficult to manage
distributed transactions so if you are
using secure rest pattern together with
a relational database like sequel
without even store without even sourcing
it's very tough to handle distribute
transactions which means that it gives
you even more boilerplate code even more
overhead so instead of using this
approach will rather sometimes use like
typical even store and we have a talk
about even sourcing so this is basically
if break store for our events in the
correct order so what you can do you can
put this single line of code in the even
handler in is gonna save your even to
the store
obviously you don't you
have to do it manually you can just
subscribe to the even store and
automatically safe every even instead of
creating even hunger for all of them
alright it was pretty simple we have our
application
our hero game in the stream on inner
architecture finished it's working right
we have a comment we have an event we
are updating entities we are performing
business logic super awesome now we have
to introduce these features these music
features artifacts and coins let's have
a look at our architecture once again we
have this common common handler events
even handler there is a missing piece
here and the missing piece is a saga
saga subscribed to incoming events and
can dispatch comments ken doesn't have
to but can so if you're a family are
with for example angular angular has ng
rx package saga is a like a like an
effect if you're familiar with react
there is a read of saga which basically
implements a kind of side effects
package like it features for you in this
in this fall Redux world alright let's
move to the artifacts how to implement
artifacts in Eric's GS way in the
reactive way so that's the son saga is
it's a kind of property actually it's a
property which is equal to functions so
it's a function which has a saga
decorator on top of it it's a function
which takes this even stream so you have
to think about it like this timeline
that I've shown you like events can
occur over time and since we have this
stream we have to do a few things first
of all to recall everybody we have to
drop an item every time when the hero
slays dragon which level is at least
free so what we have to do we have to
filter even stream by even type which is
hero slate dragon even right there a
declarative way we have to filter this
even based on the dragon level because
we are not interested in any other
dragons and if that's the case
I have to map this event to the
appropriate comment so this drop item
feature is done in this way we have
items now let's move to the coins part
so cones is even much even even more
simple think about two different streams
we have a stream of hero slate dragon
events and we have a stream of hero find
out item events what we have to do we
have a merge operator from XG s we are
taking these two streams and we combine
them together so then we can simply take
either of these heroes they dragon even
or hero found item even and merge it
based on the probability which is
obviously math.random and we can merge
map it to nested stream it might be an
empty so we are not gonna dispatch
anything or drop coins comment and
obviously we then have to create an
appropriate common handler for our drop
King's comment and so on and so on so
again just to give you a short
high-level view we have a comment then
we have a comment handler that hero
slays the dragon we are dispatching and
even in our case just one single even at
the diagram you can see multi we can see
multiple events because you don't have
to necessarily dispatch only one single
event you can dispatch multiple events
but we are dispatching only wanna me
don't need anything else
and then we are processing our even
Insider even handler however our sagas
two sagas subscribe to the events
omission and based on some conditions
can lead to dispatch in another comment
drop coins comment or drop item comment
so it's a highly scalable solution very
extensible really like you can add more
things only to the saga react on events
instead of putting more imperative code
inside the services because in the
this is layer you mostly have like 20 or
30 or even 40 it's growing over time
it's more and more complicated business
functionalities here you can split them
into different pieces of the
architecture which makes it incredibly
scalable over time but I as I said it
brings a lot of overhead a lot of
boilerplate
as you can see common hard lers comment
even hundreds events and also sagas
pretty much the same as in the redux
right just increment the value one line
no action reducer state and so on and so
on all right
lastly I would like to say that nest so
the nest framework is is open sourced
meaning that we are totally driven by
the community and therefore I encourage
everyone everyone here to join this
little revolution to contribute to help
us growing to make it even better
framework every every single day also
there are a couple of companies and even
more than 100 people already who decided
to continue to like donate support us
with the donation which is pretty
amazing a big thank you to all of them
and if you are looking for counseling
like if you are struggling with a
migration of your node application nest
or you're looking for expertise
consulting in Engler and architectural
things around just visit the website
send us a message and we'll talk so
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]